it might be odd to think of wolves in
Germany but there are an estimated 300
in Brandenburg alone that's the state
surrounding Berlin the Wolves usually
hunt at dusk or at night silently and
impacts and their number is growing
farmers are all too aware the packs hunt
wild animals but also livestock out on
the fields it's taking its toll
financially for Brandenburg farmer
Jurgen fences the wolf's are causing so
much trouble he's worried about his
livelihood he lost 40 calves in 2017 ten
times more than the year before
Brandenburg has responded to the farmers
plight they've authorized hunters to
shoot wolves if as in the case of you
and Francis they have repeatedly
attacked livestock or a human being
animal protectionists are concerned
Stephane haka has been tracking a pack
of wolves in his neighborhood for years
and is convinced the situation isn't
that dramatic and as long as the wolf
isn't lured in with food it will avoid
humans
you see these fresh wolf tracks only a
few hours old
in nine years I've only seen one five or
six times they're usually very shy
they just observe us I imagine Hika
mostly observes the wolves using camera
traps he turn because he heard the
camera flash so he can't see it he's
wearing KOICA says the animals should be
allowed to live in Brandenburg
permission to shoot wolves is
unnecessary and only a cause for
scaremongering
this is an endangered species the few
wolves we have aren't going to wildly
multiply at 30% a year I can't listen to
this argument anymore we barely have
1,000 wolves in Germany barely 1000 but
for most hunters that's still too many
the Brandenburg hunting Association
demands a more limited population they
say this large predator doesn't fit in
the modern landscape they want fixed
shooting quotas and more freedom to
decide when a wolf must be shot some say
just a single pack and an entire German
reserve would be enough one pack is
about four to six animals they can live
sustainably they can rear their young
have a home it's fair to everyone if you
want to see more wolves go to the zoo
getting everyone on the same page is
going to be a challenge but amid the
bitter disputes between hunters farmers
and animal rights groups hawaika still
has hope for the future of the wolves in
germany we need to work together until
it's better working with the hunting
community like this is groundbreaking
time you just get resistance down the
wolves shoot them all and I just shake
my head coming up seven wolves were
driven out of the country
100 years ago integrating the animals
back into modern-day Germany despite the
difficulties is a task only humans can
do